Worried and angry parents are
turning out in droves in Tehran
and other cities across
Iran, challenging
that regime, demanding answers
after a wave of suspected
poisoning attacks
on hundreds
of schoolgirls across the country.
Some parents are calling
these targeted and deliberate attempts
to keep their girls
from getting an education.
Let's go to our Nima Elbagir
who's been covering this for us.
She joins us from London Good morning.
This is really a significant development
over the weekend
because these are parents
in rage
demanding answers from the regime.
Obviously, Poppy, and at huge
personal risk.
We've uncovered
evidence that highlights
the extent of the risks
parents are taking.
Take a look at this
Furious parents outside
an education office in Tehran
challenging Iranian authorities desperate
for answers
after what is believed
to be
the worst day of incidents
of suspected poisonings at girls schools.
These videos were filmed on Saturday,
which marks the start of the school week
in Iran.
For months now, Iranian schoolgirls
and their families
have been speaking out
about incidents of suspected
poisoning
The numbers of incidents
reported to CNN in the dozens.
Then over the weekend, dozens more.
CNN was able to verify
these new incidents using video
and witness testimony.
Across ten provinces, the U.S.
and others are calling
for Iran's authorities
to investigate these incidents.
But speaking to CNN,
medical sources
say they have been barred
by hospital administrators
from sharing details
of symptoms and test results,
even with the patient's parents.
We dub this doctor's
voice for his safety.
I'm inside Iran.
My phone is being monitored.
I can't show any more with you.
Iran's interior minister,
after months of vague statements
now says
suspicious samples have been found
and are being assessed at laboratories.
Parents, though, say
they don't trust authorities
to investigate
To hell with this country and its rulers.
We would be better off without a leader.
This is our country.
They don't know what they're doing.
They don't even have medicine.
All the incidents
begin in a similar manner
as described to us by students.
A noxious smell.
And then I felt dizzy and fainted.
I had dimness of vision
and heart palpitations.
All of us had identical
symptoms, palpitations.
My hands and legs were numb and frozen.
I was shaken.
We had tears coming out of our eyes.
With no one so far
held to account and parents
no closer to answers.
Many continue
to risk their lives
to challenge Iran's authorities
The US State Department
last week called for Iranian authorities
to investigate these incidents.
But as you see there,
people inside
Iran do not trust authorities
not only to investigate this,
but with the lives of
their children Poppy.
And never
before you go
now here in the United States,
the head of the Senate
Foreign Relations
Committee, Senator Menendez,
is calling on the United Nations
to investigate
what CNN's investigation has uncovered.
Are these secret torture centers across
the country? Is that right?
Absolutely.
And we've
already been hearing
from some of our sources this morning,
and they really feel it's
a huge vindication
for the huge risks
that they took in speaking to us.
But just to kind of pull out a little bit
and also to contextualize this for you
speaks to the ways
that the US is now
pushing much harder
on an international stage
because the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee is the US government's
foreign policy lead.
And this is a big push on their part
to specifically say
Iranian authorities
need to be investigated internationally.
It speaks to the US
trying to take a harder line on
what the Iran
regime is doing to its own people, Poppy.
The real question is going to be
how much access can the U.N.
get and what sort of teeth of course
do they have now?
Great reporting as always. Thank you.